[Musique]
je suis robert le boss 23,7 leurs deux
guerriers dans les yeux
vous devez vraiment apprendre à
contrôler votre tempérament il causera
votre perte
ah ah
tout top
qui rapportera la tête de robert leroux
recevra la somme de 50 pièces d'or
là
vous le combattre et à mort no 3 il
n'est pas mon roi
qui sait robert bruce
il se cache ici
fouillez de photo co quand quelqu'un
viendra pour tuer le roi il faudra se
battre
nous avons connu les cosses sous
l'emprise d'une main puissante
maintenant nous la libérerons me
rejoignez vous dans ce combat
[Musique]
dix mille épouse me dit me lemaire nous
savoir que nous sommes ne sont pas morts
en vain
les siennes
l'écart qu'on a émis ne perdez pas
espoir
ce n'est que l'on enjambe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]